the accompanying table gives the probability
distribution of the random variable y
where the amount of memory is put
the amount of memory you find in a purchase Drive.
So what is this table mean? I'll show you to see the F now.
you have
you're going to store.
Or let's say you're looking at the purchase
customers have made.
point five
this is the probability number.
between 0 and 1
.5. We can think about this as 5% but flash
drives with one gig of memory one gigabyte of memory.
10% but
or the
I'm making mistake here. There is
a 10% probability.
That the two GB flash drive
would be sold.
There's a 35% probability.
That the flash drive with four GB.
storage moving stored and then
Percent probability that the flash drive with 8GB
would be sold and then for the 16GB it there's
a sharper decline.
I think today it would be like 256 would be the most.
128 256 GB
flash shares or sold most and then when you
get to like two terabyte 3 terabyte the big release massive storage
ones.
They probably starts to decline because
most people wouldn't probably need that much storage.
But its same story is here not many if you
look at this table just for a few seconds. It's I mean, we only
have five items in the random variable you
can see that
Very few people buy one GB like it's not
enough whereas 16 is too much.
Okay again, let's imagine. This
is a long time ago.
So
here's how here's what the community commutative distribution
function is about.
Determine F of Y.
the CDF
for each five possible values of Y. I'm going to open this up.
So whereas the PDF, excuse me, the pmf
the previous example this one.
This one acts asks for a specific.
probability
or the probability for a specific value
the CDF asks for the probably of
a range of values like Elite up to
like less than or equal or greater than
or equal.
Like what is the cumulative? Like? How does it probably accumulate?
as you progress down the
table of the random variable. Let's look at that. Let's look at
the notation.
So you're saying that's just
a function?
That's just that's a that's another name for the CDF.
Okay, let's focus on this part. If you're not familiar with function notation you're
saying
What is the probability I can uppercase p means? What is the probability?
What is the probability that the random variable?
or what is the probability for the random variable when you
have
flash drive storage 1GB or
less
Well, we only have one gigabyte.
There's nothing less than one gigabyte.
So we asking
what is the probability that you would get one out of?
Or you would get this store this much space out of the other five spaces.
There are there's a typo here.
Yeah, so what is the so now
what you're looking at first of all this table. This is the complete.
This is the random variable and one column. They probably distribution and
the other column they're both together now.
This is what you would use to plot a graph.
Okay.
We only have one item.
So even though we're asking.
What what is the probability that you would have one GB
or less? We only have one GB anyway.
So we just say y equals to 1 in other words. What is
the probability that someone will buy a flash
drive. That is one GB.
Well, we don't need to calculate the probability distribution that has
been calculated before but it's 0.5.
That's given.
We're just looking at the notation for the CDF.
the next one asks
What is the probability?
That a y less than or equal to 2 that is to
say what is the probability that the customer will buy one GB
flash or 2GB Flash?
Well in order to evaluate this you add up the probability so
you accumulate so you say 0.5 plus
0.10.
And that gives you 0.50.
So the probability that the customer will buy two GB
or 1 GB is the probability of
buying one GB all of the plus the probability
of buying two GP and they both add up to 15 right
0.5 plus 0.10 15.
Let's look at one more. What is the probability that the customer will
buy?
In some experiment the customer will buy 4GB flash
2G. Oh rather 4GB
Flash and below.
Well, we don't have 3gb. So we have we have 4GB. Those are
the options we have 4GB.
You have 2GB and 1GB.
So what is the probability that they will buy 4GB 2GB 1GB?
Well, if you want to know the probability the cumulative probability
add up the probability for all for
these three outcomes.
So for four we get 0.35.
That's that's probably that a 4GB flash drive
will be sold for two is 10 point 10
point 10.
And then one is point five if you add this up.
You get point point five?
You can check this for yourself, but that's it has up
to this.
So this is this is this is important Point here the probability
that they would you know.
By up to or up to 4 is
0.5. So it's increasing.
The thing is what the cmf and we will see this in later examples. It starts
to Plateau. So here we can see it's trying to
grow quickly. It went from point. It went from 5% to
15% to 40 50%
But at one point it starts to plateau.
And we'll look at examples of that later. And that's where the CDF you know.
makes things more clear
makes things clearer
then of course we have what is the probability that they would
buy eight and below and we can see
it goes up to 90.
0.9.
Obviously if you enter the probability for all the
values.
It works its way up to point nine.
And of course if you include the last random variable, it adds
up to 1 so you're asking what is the probability that someone will
buy 16 GB 8 GB 4GB 2GB 1GB.
What is it? Probably any of them will be bought effectively. Well one
100% one of them will be bought.
That's what the CDF allows you
to understand.
You can start to see the probability increase.
With you know, as you make your
way down the random variable, this is not always the case. It won't always look like look
this way. Like I said in some cases it will start the plateau.
and if you're trying to
determine like how much should you spend for the probability
of some or a set of events to increase?
And you start to see a plateau.
You may want to for example stop.
At a given value as opposed to continuing down the
line.
Because the probability is not going to change the more you do it.
Okay, this is what we call.
What is the word I'm trying to use here or the phrase diminishing returns?
The CDF will help you recognize the diminishing
returns.
But this is the notation again. This is about notation.
Okay.